je vais vous laisser raconter avec vos
mots votre terrible expérience de femme
battue mais juste avant est quelque
chose de très singulier dans votre
parcours qu'il est généralement c'est
que ça s'est très mal passé avec le
premier homme de votre vie si je puis
dire avec votre père puisque vous avez
été en quelque sorte renier vos parents
attendait un garçon c'est une fille qui
est apparue il ya des parents qui
peuvent être plus ou moins déçu mais la
déception a pris un tour tout à fait et
caricatural hyperbolique
vous avez été évincé de la famille
racontez nous avons commencé sur moi
alors déjà être présentée comme une
femme battue
ça me gêne un peu ce titre là je fous là
devant nous et nous préféré qu'on dise
une femme qui a combattu un homme fou
par exemple qui est sorti de violence ou
mes femmes battues ou ai je fait c'est
un peu un accord on va revenir là dessus
mais juste un mot sur 7 sur vos
premières années qui n'est pas acquis a
subi oui voilà le tour ou non c'est un
facilement une femme qui s'en est sorti
tout simple oui mais dans le café fans
c'est quelqu'un de violent femmes
survivantes on dit souvent
voilà l'anglais on dit aujourd'hui oui
j'étais donc une fille mon père
attendait un garçon
donc j'ai été placé en famille d'accueil
puisque ma mère n'a pas assumé le fait
que je sois une fille et par la suite
effectivement j'ai rencontré mon mari
mon ex mari avec qui j'ai une expérience
douloureuse expérience douloureuse ça a
commencé comment est ce que vous pouvez
daté ce qui a eu un jour précis où ça a
basculé du côté de l'as de la violence
conjugale
on va dire j'étais un petit peu perdues
je n'avais pas de repères familiaux et
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai rencontré
mon ex mari qui a réussi à ma porte et
quelques bases familial que je n'avais
pas il m'a aidé sur plusieurs points
notamment le point financier tout ce qui
était aussi glamour
des carences affectives que j'avais eu
des couacs comme profession pardon de sa
profession il était alors dans le livre
j'ai mis qu'il était charpentier mais
c'était pas son métier parce que pour
des problèmes d'anonymat j'ai préféré
modifier quelques qui part à m on va
dire qu'il était charpentier donc il
était à son compte
c'était quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup de
charisme qui savent s exprimer qu'il y
avait beaucoup de culture générale et
donc qui m'a séduite qui avait un rôle
de père aussi envers moi il était plus
âgée que vous n'avez quand il avait 15
ans puisque moi oui en fait vous avez
énumérer tous les éléments qui lui
permet telle emprise sur vous voilà
c'est ça la le côté financier le côté
charisme mais puisque vous avez énuméré
ses terres de faire là bas les
charpentiers les charpentiers j'ai
toujours dit que ça descend métier
vieille histoire très vieille histoire
vous avez des enfants demain oui j'aime
une fille avec wii qui à 18 ans là
aujourd'hui maintenant et donc voilà
donc j'ai eu une fille avait là ce que
vous avez décrit c'est plutôt le côté
positif d'une relation à par l'emprise
mais quand est ce que vous m'avez
demandé d'écrire le début voilà
exactement ils m'ont dit c'est quand est
ce que le chaland bascule du mauvais
côté sa basse que jamais en au début en
général ça prend du temps ce genre de
choses dont bien entendu rien à dire un
an et demi maintenant
et ensuite oui enfin nguyen hong hanh
après quand j'avais j'avais 16 ans donc
un an c'est long quand on a 16 ans quand
même qu'on n'a pas la même perception du
temps à cet âge-là je pense déjà appris
qu'elle forme au début donc je prends ça
comme aux malades étaient beaucoup de
comme si j'étais coupé un petit peu de
mes émotions de ce que je ressentais
réellement et comme je voulais lui
plaire en fait je me mettais à aimer
tout ce qu'il est mais en fait pour
qu'ils soient contents de moi et qui
m'abandonne pas surtout correspondre
dévitalisées oui correspond le plus
possible en fait à ce qu'il attendait de
moi pour lui plaire et pour avoir ce que
j'attendais vie c'est-à-dire qu'ils
m'aiment et qui me regardent mais
j'aimerais savoir à quel moment
est rendu compte qu'ils avaient
pathologie sur l' influence du net que
vous avez reçus ou par une réflexion
personnelle je réfléchissais beaucoup je
voyais bien qu'il y avait un souci mais
je m'en suis pas aperçue tout de suite
je voyais qu'il y avait quand même une
nuisance chez lui quelque chose comme
une prédation quelque chose de huy
dunant privat en fait mais quelque part
ça séduisent et un petit peu à l'époque
parce que ça me prend je me sentais
protégés étant donné qu'il avait
beaucoup de charisme et de caractère il
me protégeait du reste du monde en fait
et j'avais pas besoin d'affronter le
monde avec lui est-ce que vous avez
l'impression un peu je dirais entre
guillemets imaginaire que la violence
qu'il témoignait pourraient vous être
utiles pour une violence contre des gens
qui vous agréent serait un non mais par
contre par son intermédiaire voilà donc
ce a contribué à faire prolonger à
continuer la situation sans demander de
l'aide pour pour le bourreau qui vous
protège en fait voilà qui promet mais la
situation se prolonge mais s'aggrave
nettement parce que plusieurs reprises
les cochons tellement violent que vous
craignez pour votre vie oui est-ce que
sur l'effet de certaines violences
avaient eu recours à au domaine médical
hospitalier
vous êtes sur ces 8 c'est une séance oui
plein finances
alors oui j'ai déjà des hospices fin pas
des hospitalisations mais j'ai déjà été
à l'hôpital avec des jours d'itt était
en fait quand un homme qui fait 30 e 30
kg puisque vous s'allonge sur vous et
vous étrangle avec son bras c'est
difficile déjà de se défendre et j'ai
ouï plusieurs fois j'ai senti que je que
la vie peut être me quitter ouais je
pense que vous étiez à l'hôpital est ce
que vous avez pensé peut-être vous
confierez des médecins avait informé m
confidentialité maman qui vous posent
des questions mais après moi j'avais 20
ans à l'époque donc c'était peut-être
moins développés
votre vie vous étiez isolé à votre
domicile avec lui où il y avait un
travail des noms je n'avais pas
travaillé à l'époque je vivais en huit
clos pendant il contrôler mon
alimentation les programmes télé je
regardais je n'avais pas droit de lire
non plus et c'est vrai que ça a pris du
temps pour moi aussi d'aller vers les
gens parce que j'étais très introverti
déjà d'un
naturellement et sas a amplifié en fait
le fruit d'années j'avais du mal à aller
vers les gens et pas le droit au faux
pas donné les raisons que j'arrive à
faire les gens pour le pas le droit de
pas le droit de lire il y avait une
raison et vous invoquez il fallait que
tout passons par son filtre en fait
c'était dans les dictatures
oui voilà mais ça il y à l'emprise il ya
les interdictions etc
et il ya la violence physique quand on a
été à deux doigts de la mort où il se
remet vous rentrez chez vous est ce qu'à
un moment vous vous dites il faut que je
m'enfuis il faut se bat bien sûr est ce
que vous êtes ont fait un dock salle
parce que d'un côté j'avais envie d'y
croire
j'avais envie de croire que ça pouvait
s'arranger je croyais vraiment un ami un
idéal familial je me raccroche est
vraiment à ça donc quelque part j'ai
essayé d'avancer avec lui mais
parallèlement je faisais mes démarches
pour m'en aller
donc c'était un peu traître de faire ça
mais non mais c'est important on voit
que je suivais en parle plus c'est
important ce que vous dites parce que
dans les cantons
on a affaire à des cas comme le vôtre
beaucoup de gens disent mais pourquoi
les femmes ne partent pas immédiatement
et c'est pas si facile c'est ce que vous
expliquez non parce que je pense que
quelque part on essaye d'y croire on
sera on se raccroche parce que ces
personnes là ils ont des bons côtés
aussi c'est pas que des monstres ils ont
aussi parfois une lucidité
ce sont des gens qui rejoignent sympa
survie à soigner les plaies qu'il
provoque donc ce qu'ils soient eux les
propres médecins de leur propre
maléfices même donc si vous voulez c'est
un cercle vicieux en des côtés très cdu
qui pense avec un toutes les blessures
qu'ils provoquent même il est là le
cercle vicieux
en fait ils sont des virtuoses de la
dépendance et à merveille de fer
continue et la dépendance et comme
quelque part moi j'avais un terrain
aussi un an à être dépendante je pense
j'avais déjà des qualités de sélective
très forte du fait de mes parents ma
mère
donc c'est vrai que j'avais quand même
je pense que peut-être mais ça
n'arriverait pas à notre futur
repères légende à qui la dépendance
bourrel a besoin d'intervenir
ils repèrent hokkaido bonsoir merci
beaucoup pour votre témoignage
ce qui me frappe quand même lorsque vous
avez dit c'est que vous aviez 16 ans au
départ oui donc à l'instant on parlait
d'enfance maltraitée mais vous étiez une
adolescente aperçu à peine sortis de
l'enfance
on parle de la manière dont les
prédateurs identifie des failles chez
les personnes donc le fait d'être une
très très jeune fille de vous priver de
certaines manières de votre émancipation
ne vous permettant pas de lire ont
d'abord identifié une jeune femme qui
avait été victime de brimades de la part
de sa famille et de effectivement de
2,40
vous aviez des carences affectives comme
vous l'aviez dit je trouve que c'est
quand même un comportement ou vraiment
où est cet homme là mais quinze ans que
plus que vous donc vous imaginez d'avoir
30 ans oui là donc s'associer revoir ces
mêmes en indien on est donc déjà dans
une relation qui n'était même pas et
passerelles n'était pas saine
à la base effectivement vous avez
identifié comme quelqu'un qu'il pouvait
formaté et enfermé dans une relation
abusive sans que vous n'ayez les clés
pour pouvoir en sortir et effectivement
c'est là une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai été réservé par rapport à cette
possibilité de confinement parce que des
jeunes femmes comme vous l'étiez à
l'époque
privé de liens extérieurs privés même de
la capacité à se diriger par l'extérieur
pour appeler au secours sont davantage
mis en danger dans des constant des
circonstances où effectivement elles
sont isolées avec leurs bourreaux et
leurs bourreaux leur donnent
l'impression qu'ils sont tous pour elle
et ça c'est vraiment ce que je voulais
vraiment pas un problème du confinement
actuellement c'est qu'on n'en voit pas
le bout en fait et ça vaudrait peut-être
faire un compliment
un confinement street comme ça quelqu'un
anglo street ce que vous pensez pas ce
que vous avez vécu sur la place
financière
en imaginant qu'il faudrait que ces
femmes qui sont enfermés toute la
journée avec des bouts en fuel de
l'ascendant sur elle vous pensiez que
peuvent s'en sortir il ya des fenêtres
de leur expansion c'est que c'est vrai
que le fait de ne pas avoir
d'interactions sociales d'être en forme
donc c'était permanente sécurité
financière le fait d'avoir des dans un
climat où si on dit que la maladie est
présente c'est amplifie la fragilité
psychologique et je pense que ça déploie
l'emprise possible de personnes comme
celle là donc oui je pense que c'est la
certitude aussi qu'ils jouent dans le
dans le tout à l'heure on parle pas on a
beaucoup parlé pendant confinement de la
question du coût économique du
confinement et la situation sanitaire
mais je pense que le coup mentale n'ait
absolument
estimé à sa juste mesure et il n'y a pas
longtemps j'entendais on va parler des
universités mais le président de la
conférence des universités qu'il disait
qu' on était dans une situation
quasiment deux cocottes cocotte-minute
sociales et humaines qui pouvait exposer
et je pense que ça s'applique pas
seulement au monde étudiant mais on
prépare un monde où les gens sauront
dans un état de détresse psychologique
et ne mesure pas tout va vers le corps
est rien on va vers le cerveau et le
psychisme c'est très étonnant on va
parler des étudiants est ce que pensait
pas en effet comme le disait karim que
le confinement s'il y avait un
confinement et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
s'est passé dans les autres sans nier ça
aggraverait encore lorsque vous avez
subi là le confinement il dure trop
longtemps en fait c'est il faudrait
faire quelque chose de strictes et
qu'ils soient plus courts et pourquoi on
puisse être libéré rapidement des pays
par exemple taïwan
ils ont ils ont vraiment fait quelque
chose de strictes il ya eu que sept
morts oui mais si bien qu'on finit par
vous attirer des demi-mesures oui mais
quand vous êtes enfermé avec un conjoint
un mari violent
la confine mon string ou là depuis le
mois de novembre c'est quand même il ya
des gens qui on n'est pas un profit non
mais je dire on est quand même dans le
sens qui va la vie sociale pour le
parent et que je comprenne que je
comprenne bien vous vous seriez pour 1
re confinement vous seriez favorable
confirme qu'on puisse par exemple quinze
jours trois semaines pour qu'on puisse
être libre condamnations à mort dont
certaines femmes et pour certains
enfants une condamnation comme une peine
de prison avec un tortionnaire
[Musique]
on a les chiffres qui dit 65% de
violences ou les lieux en plus oui avec
le confinement et vous dites mais il
faudrait un confinement de 15 jours
s'est dit en fait une fois pour toutes
le problème c'est que après par exemple
votre confinement de 15 jours s'il ya
deux ans une deuxième variante troisième
variante 4s que si la veux dire c'est un
confinement ou après un confinement
bombe a soufflé pendant quinze jours
trois semaines et puis après on va pas
partir
enfin si meilleur du travail parce
qu'elle est connue c'est ça qui veut
dire qu'on peut pas raisonner comme si
un malheur
pas raisonner comme ça parce qu'on est
passionné par ce après quoi est ce que
vous ne craignez pas qu'un conte filmant
même de 15 jours ça soit en effet ça
sera des incidents des morts de faim en
ce moment là d'accueillir des femmes et
comment vous sarah vous avez réussi à
vous sortir de cette situation vous avez
vécu pendant alors moins au fait je me
projetais beaucoup dans l'avenir et jeux
pour moi j'imagine et un avenir meilleur
pour ma fille je n'avais pas envie de
rester dans ce contexte là donc je pense
qu'après c'est souvent le fait de se
raccrocher à la vie en fait quand on est
vraiment motivé je pense qu'on peut s'en
sortir et avait pu voir les jouets
positif vous avez pu vous tourner vers
des professionnels vers des associations
j'ai été aidé par une assistante sociale
qui était très impliqué dans mon
histoire et j'ai eu pas mal de gens qui
étaient très sensibles en fait à mon
histoire donc je me suis raccroché en
fait à tous ces gens positifs autour de
moi mais pas l'enfant votre mousse q les
une deux quand même mais malgré tous ces
gens là qui vous ont aidé à qu'elle vous
étiez réceptive
vous pensiez quand même que les choses
pourraient être positives dans le futur
conjugal mais que lui comme je disais
tout à l'heure en fait d'un côté
j'essayais de d'y croire mais bien de
gens parallèle je faisais des démarches
pour partir c'était un duel en fait en
moi je c'est difficile à expliquer et
est ce que vous pensez que ces démarches
dans un pays paralysé confiné où des
institutions sociales sont là pour la
plupart fermés est-ce que vous pensez
que ces femmes dans ces cas là aurait
cette possibilité de se tourner de
trouver une assistante sociale qui
pourrait suivre leurs quatre compères
c'est ça j'espère aller aujourd'hui je
sais pas ce qu'il en est mais ce que je
vois c'est que depuis le mouvement tout
etc
il ya quand même beaucoup plus de femmes
qui s'expriment il ya une libération de
la parole et je peux pas leur demi tous
des enfants
le problème c'est qu'il ya pas de mitu
des enfants ah oui leur définition il
faut des règles intervenir
j'écoute j'ai écouté tout à l'heure le
témoignage d'hakan j'écoute le
témoignage de sarah et ça fait écho en
moi puisque pendant le premier
confinement g j'ai quelqu'un qui est
très proche de moi qui est journaliste
sportif et qui a profité de son audience
auprès d'eux
un gamin pour pour lever le secret sur
son enfance d'enfants battus et vos
parcours le parcours de la can je pense
aussi à lies loufoque qui a aujourd'hui
qui a été un enfant battu à plat ses
qualités en font passer par bonds et qui
aujourd'hui un éducateur un travailleur
social doit montrer qu'il ya un espoir
qui en avenir que c'est possible et que
ce n'est pas une fatalité de se faire
battre des fois jusqu'à la mort ça c'est
la première des choses est la deuxième
des choses la tribune donc de de mon ami
il appelle à une chose et je pense que
ça douze doigts ça doit tous nous
interroger sur de nouvelles solidarités
on doit tous être acteur en fait dans
ses combats contre les violences faites
aux femmes contre les enfants maltraités
quand un gamin se fait battre dans un
immeuble est bon on peut pas juste
tourner la tête tu vas faire la sourde
oreille et laisser passer quand on
entend une femme se faire battre eh ben
on ne doit pas tourner la tête quand on
voit des marques de violence
on doit pas comme ça fermait les yeux
ont des noms mais tous acteurs et en
comptent chacun on est encore plus
acteur dans ces confinement l'a
peut-être que cette fois ci la fois où
on va entendre ces violences eh ben il
aura pas tuer l'enfant ou la femme en
question mais on sait on n'en sait rien
pour la faune est ce que quelqu'un est
intervenu en fait vous sahara par les
crises à part les travailleurs sociaux
ou des voisins des amis sont intervenus
oui il ya des voisins il ya des
personnes bien sûr il y avait plein de
gens qui savaient que j'étais battu et
que mon mari et mon ex mariés tfo et
tout le monde le savait mais être qu'on
vous a aidé alors est ce que vous
apporte plus de deux parties après non
oui j'ai partez vous a porté plainte
mais ça sert à rien fait du tout
d'accord six sorties toutes ses chances